I'm bono Felton the CEO of diffraction
analysis a research company focusing
exclusively on NGA issues the thing that
I found the most interesting in the
conference so far is the emphasis on
financing financing is a crucial topic
when it comes to an exploration access
deployment and quite often it's a
question that is overlooked but actually
it's probably one of the single aspects
of the market that is lacking at this
point in time so it was very interesting
to have a set of speakers focusing
specifically on that issue and taking a
fairly positive view of network
deployments infrastructure deployments
as sound investments so that's the one
thing that I would say was the most
striking my name is yesterday's fire and
I'm marketing manager for Dallas gap for
me it's been a wonderful experience
participating in the ftth conference I
think that it's been wonderfully
organized and it's been a great
opportunity to meet with all the
important people within the industry
hello my name is Sophie buitoni I am a
member of the board of directors of the
ftth come to Europe I think we've been
through fantastic even today personally
I've been particularly interested by the
message delivered by our keynote speaker
this morning Carlota Perez which was
really a positive message that was given
to all
the industry of the fiber to the home
this is very encouraging to see that
when looking at analogy with previous
technological revolution we're in the
right way in deploying first
infrastructure and that we can expect a
wonderful golden age behind with some
new services on whatever and what was
really interesting that we received so
many positive feedback from the
participants in the room that were very
pleased about this message and that most
of them came to tourism to the keynote
speaker to explain that they would we
use a lot of what happened said during
the speech to convince their own
politicians in the country in their city
to also convince the public authority of
the need to invest on to have
kind of public-private partnership to
make it successful